c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
donc
je vais d'abord sur l'île de pom ans qui
est à 3 heures au large de rome ensuite
je pars à las vegas et je fais un gros
trip entre las vegas et los angeles
money maneval et le lac mead le grand
canyon et et tout ça donc je vais savoir
aventure
[Musique]
je vais faire cet été je vais m'en faire
une sangle abdominale qu'un père à qui
je vais faire du badminton et nourrir
les cygnes les disputes que j'ai croisés
qui parie qu'on n'a pas le temps
d'apprendre à lire et surtout surtout
surtout je vais rien dire patrick et
rien n'a rien
[Musique]